one of my favorite books catch-22
classic World War 2 novel about World
War 2 and and here you are making that
story and who's involved but George
Clooney George Clooney's in it but he's
also I think a producer reducing it
yeah he's involved in many levels
directing as around so I'm guessing are
you hanging out with George Clooney when
you make this um he's there and we got
along great
but I in my mind before I went I was
like we're we're gonna be best friends
you know but now I have no way of
contacting him I don't even have an
email I assume it's George Clooney and
hotmail but I really did before I went
I'm like ah man it's good it's gonna be
me him and Brad you know just like
playing playing pranks and also having
serious conversations about the Middle
East and and what was it I mean what was
was it were there moments where you felt
like okay here's a second we're sitting
around we're all eating lunch and
waiting to shoot the next scene and I'm
just gonna say something that's gonna be
clever yep and it never happened I had
so much time to get it right and I never
once did he'd be like hey what's going
on man and I'd be like ha ha ha swish
goes the basket you know it got to a
point where I was planning my end of the
conversation at haunt know cuz he's a
great storyteller so I'm like if I just
ask him a good question he'll he'll go
off and that'll be and then I'd seem and
I forget the question I wanted to ask so
I'd see him I'd be like oh she's 11 that
must have been you and at least 10 other
guys
I think you sounded like you did really
well